this podcast has bad words hmm live from
the Gov my name is Joshua Fields Milburn
and I am Ryan Nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists live in Adelaide
[Applause]
I was awesome and it's so good to be
rattled late you know what I got to tell
you that Loki this might be my favorite
city in Australia hands down it reminds
me of Missoula Montana with Los Angeles
weather yeah it's it is such a subtle
town we've had a great time these last
24 hours by the way we'll get to as many
questions we have in the time allotted I
know we we never never able to get to
all of them but we'll get through as
many as we can
howdy what's your name Adelle get closer
to the mic please
Adelle where you from beautiful oh my
gosh you said your city
nice to meet you don't speak Scottish
[Music]
yeah what is Jinlong canteen the best
Thai food Natalie oh Jinlong canteen all
right so here's what's happening she is
she's giving the answer we have to then
present the question of what what is the
best Thai food in Adelaide that was your
question how can we help
[Music]
[Music]
just like Jesus would have wanted it
right it's funny I walk through the
target here and I had to buy like some
markers
to sign books and it was just rows of
chocolate bunnies I mean I think that's
all the store was I'm starting to get it
okay so so what's the question okay yes
here's the bad news this is the wrong
time to ask this question because Easter
is like right around the corner right
and and so the the time what we want to
ask right now is how do I keep Christmas
gifts from coming into my life because
it really has to do with the preparation
and the preparation for a holiday in
this case avoiding the excessive
consumerism associated with said holiday
because it's not that you want to avoid
the holiday right you want to be able to
celebrate the holiday without indulging
in overindulgent consumerism
yes so so I think the same is true with
birthdays and with Valentine's Day and
with Christmas and with birthdays and
whatever else is around the corner we
have commodified love right we just and
I were just joking backstage a few
moments ago yeah here's the thing we've
we've heard this same before that
gift-giving is a love language right and
I think that's like saying Pig Latin is
a Romance language here's the thing
giving a physical gift is not
necessarily an act of love but I think
what we mean when we say gift-giving is
a love language language what we
actually mean is contribution or adding
value to another person's life is a love
language here's the problem with that
we're doing a really shitty job with our
holidays in adding value to other
people's lives because what you're
telling me right now is I'm not gonna
get any value or my
family's not gonna get any value from
the hordes of crap that come in here in
fact it's going to extract value from my
holiday and thus from my life and that's
a problem right here's the other problem
though it's too late to tell people that
about about Easter and so what we can do
when you stir rolls around and say thank
you very much set it to a saw to the
side and and it is what it is for this
holiday but when it comes to Christmas
now right now well actually we're even
getting late now you want to start
planting the seeds of expectations and
here's what you want to do cuz right now
you're saying no I don't want that stuff
no no no no no no people don't want to
hear no especially when they're saying
this is my love language and I will show
you how much I love you no you want to
tell them yes and so instead of saying
no tell them what you're saying yes to
the better gifts would be experiences
the better gifts would be consumables
the better gift would be your time
because after all presence is the best
present but we want to start setting
that expectation right now plant the
seed and then water it over the course
of the next nine months until people
have the correct expectation so you're
not telling them no I don't want
anything bah humbug for whatever holiday
it is no you're telling them yes here is
what I want and here's why I want it
here's why it's important to me
it would be so much better for me if we
spent the holiday this way then if I
were to just get a bunch of plastic [ __ ]
from Target I'll tell you like I have
had that conversation with a lot of
friends and family and they will still
some of them will inevitably still end
up getting me something sometime like I
was visiting my grandmother not too long
ago and when I was leaving she was like
Ryan I know that you know you're you're
you're a businessman I don't think she
really understands what I do but she was
like I know you're a businessman
you write a lot and you probably have
stacks of paper so I want to give you
this paperweight and I was just like how
do I explain to my grandmother the cloud
I mean she doesn't even have internet
Ryan here's the funny thing man
when we when something becomes truly
useless and we have no other use
possible use for the thing we
pejoratively refer to it as a
paperweight but this one was nice a nice
little Christmas scene in it it was it
was a pretty nice paperweight and I just
remember like again not knowing how to
explain the clowder it like every time I
go to her home I have to like reprogram
my my phone number into her phone
because somehow she always ends up
deleting it I think she's doing it on
purpose honestly but but you know trying
to explain that to her she's not gonna
she's not gonna be able to like really
she I write so she is assuming I have a
lot of papers so I just I just simply
said you know what thank you very much
for this gift would you be offended if I
was to find a better home for this
because I'll be honest I've got all the
paper weights I need which is zero and
she was like oh you don't think you'll
use it I'm like no but it is a beautiful
paperweight and she was like it is isn't
it and I'm like yeah I said I would love
to give this as someone who actually
needs it and she was like yeah that
would be great
please and now I have a paperweight and
now josh has a paperweight so people are
still gonna guess you stuff so you set
the expectation or let's say you have
right now it sounds like you haven't set
the expectation that's okay it's okay
actually you know what you should do for
Christmas is when you get all the Easter
stuff you should be like boy I hope
Christmas isn't like this I don't say
like that but but but one Pete when you
have set the expectation so you start
setting that expectation with Christmas
Easter or whatever it is and then people
still nope no not at all what what what
you what I would do if I was you is is
seriously when you have all of those
what do you give each other at Easter
time is that stuff or is it just a bunch
of candy okay mostly candy so they're
trying to chop they're trying to give
you and your family diabetes okay so so
when you have all these gifts laying out
and you're and you're talking to someone
and you're like man I really love Easter
time yeah yes yes you're gonna have to
have very hard conversations I did not
promise this would be easy but you do
have to have a lot of hard conversations
and if it is if it's 20 people that you
have to talk to individually and they
mean a lot to you then you should take
time with every single one of those
people and set the expectation
if you're not willing to do it then
that's okay you could send all your
chocolate bunnies to Josh but but the
thing is is you have a nice conversation
and say hey I really appreciate the
gifts but you know what I really don't
like all the waste that happens from
this and I know that everyone who gives
me gifts loves me they love my family I
love my children but I really want to
try something different next year I
really want to try gifting no actual
gifts but you know a walk in the park or
a sunset or some type of experience
let's try something different because we
cannot I don't want to keep my family
doesn't want to keep wasting all of
these things that we get if they still
bring you gifts after you set the
expectation then there is nothing wrong
with you saying thank you for this gift
man there's gonna be a homeless kid
somewhere that's really gonna love this
maybe don't say like that but approach
it like I did with my with my
grandmother and if they don't support
you then I would just maybe correct them
a little bit and say hey I know this is
how you want to show me love I know that
you love me I don't need a chocolate
bunny and a toy to come along with it to
show me and my family are for you to
show my child that you we know that you
love us very very much if you want to
show us that you love us please support
us and trying to minimize as much waste
as possible they're very very easy I
don't say easy because it's not easy but
there are very simple ways that you can
that you can explain your your point of
view and your family's point of views
without being offensive
I'll give you one huge tip when you are
talking to someone and you're trying to
get them to alter anything whenever you
say the word you whenever you say that
word you in the conversation it is
followed by a compliment you're awesome
I love you you're amazing you all are
just the most loving family I've ever
had in my life I have a problem though
and every time you say I you put it on
yourself I have a problem all of these
gifts they really
you really stress me out and I don't
know what's wrong with me but I feel a
lot of anxiety when I have to throw away
all of these chocolate bunnies and I
know that you guys are so loving and
supportive that you're gonna really help
me not be so stressed out you see what
I'm saying
so one last tip one thing I'll add to
that is five words that changed the way
I communicate with other people when I
am asking something of them would you be
willing to and by asking a question that
way would you be willing to try
something different this year for Easter
what you family gonna say no [ __ ] you by
the way if they do say that then you
know maybe another conversation is an
order as opposed to here's how it's
going to be this Easter know hey would
you be willing to blame would you be
willing to try this out and it starts
the conversation it may not go exactly
how you want it to go but it's at least
an in it's an inroad to that
conversation thanks for your question
thank you very much
we're doing the line so mondo
howdy what's your name Sarah hey Sarah
are you from Adelaide I am welcome
there's beer Adelaide is awesome that's
my favorite part of the documentary by
the way yeah let's talk about that real
quick so our so our documentary is
called minimalism and we were putting it
together I knew that one of the things
that's really important to sort of
finish a film the last 5 or 10% to make
everything connect is the music and so
my favourite band is a band called
parlor Hawk and they've only put out two
albums ever and they're from Utah and
the lead singer is a guy named Andrew
catheter and he and his producer Nate I
baked them for six months basically to
do the soundtrack for this thing and
like flew out to California to meet with
him I'm like look I don't have any money
to pay you for this thing and like kept
asking and showing him cuts of the
documentary and eventually he's like
look what you're doing is really in line
with the message your message is aligned
with with my music I'd be happy to as
well if you just pay for studio time
well we'll make the music for this thing
and so we got not only an amazing
soundtrack for the film but I also made
a new great friend who's exceptionally
talented so it's like the power of
persistence there they're just begging
someone weekly for six months until
until they make some music for you
because I wasn't going to take no for an
answer
I know that wasn't your question though
sorry I just wondering
ha didn't happen in your life if you
think you would have found the
minimalist lifestyle eventually because
that seems to be the Kickstarter for
where you ended up now I don't know
that's the honest answer I'd like to
think I would have eventually it's like
if someone is a reckless driver on the
street and it has grown around reckless
reckless reckless and all of a sudden
they get into a car crash for me it was
like getting two car crashes in the same
month it was like boom boom my my mother
dies my marriage ends it's like that in
fact the first car crash my mother died
was really like sent me my car flying
into this other direction to where I
marriage also ended abruptly that would
have actually been prolong to probably
sever all the years had that not
happened and it's afterward I decided to
become a safer driver right because I
still had my life and I realized like oh
wow I can get out of this car crash and
still be as irresponsible as I was
before or I could take back control of
my life and be more responsible behind
the wheel because by the way it's not
just for me it's for everyone else
around me as well being being a
responsible steward of the resources
that that I have in my own life it
doesn't take a car crash to become a
safer driver but sometimes that's what
it takes in order to wake us up I mean
that was your question so I don't really
have anything to add to that I mean Ryan
didn't have a big his aha moment was was
oh [ __ ] why is Josh so happy but he
didn't have the same car crash he just
saw someone driving more safely and said
ah that looks easy yeah I mean if I were
to actually if I would have seen Colin
right without Josh sending it to me like
I would have been I would have been like
this dude is cuz I don't I didn't want
to be he literally has 52 things travels
the world every four months he moves to
new country based upon the number of
votes from his readers I did not want to
be like this peripatetic Rider
I like having it a couch
and like you know game nights and stuff
you can't really fit a couch on an
airplane so that's why Colin didn't have
one but but I will say that ya having
Josh as an example and and having other
minimalist as an example it was it was
really easy for me to make the decision
if I wouldn't have if someone else would
have presented it to me the way Josh had
I mean yeah I probably still would have
done that cuz cuz when I found out about
minimalism I wasn't like oh my god I've
never heard of this stuff before I was
like oh like this is really common sense
stuff like but unfortunately common
sense it ain't too common these days and
it took me looking at it through Colin
Joshua's Leo's Courtney's lens to really
to really see how I could apply this
very common-sense stuff to my life and
in a made sense and I wanted to actually
do it I mean everyone knows that going
out and buying a $60,000 car having a
$600 a month car payment on a six year
loan like that is you know everyone
knows intellectually that's a stupid
decision but that's what I was doing and
and being able to have other examples
that made me feel confident about you
know what I could give up that's $60,000
car and get a you know 2004 Corolla that
I still yeah our tour bus that I still
have by the way it's got approaching
like 300 thousand miles it's so funny
like so we just moved to Los Angeles in
October and we've got like this little
car park and my car is the shittiest car
in the garage like it is so like there
are like Mercedes beamers Tesla's and I
mean it's crazy and I'm just like what a
bunch of suckers with car payments man
like I am so proud to have the shittiest
car in my garage like I really do wear
it as a badge of honor when that thing
breaks down like I will I'll probably
get like something electric or you know
like try to do something environmentally
responsible but but as it stands right
now like every time it rains and like it
leaks and it like it's dripping on
Mariah nice head and I'm like wait a car
payment
luckily doesn't rain that much in LA so
we haven't experienced that too much but
but yeah I would like to think that you
know me also I would have come across
minimalism and it would have it would
have clicked with me but yeah who's to
say whether either of us would have if
those instances didn't happens really
hard to tell you know it's fascinating
right I think that yeah I wrote fiction
throughout my 20s and ultimately that
was like it was always something I
wanted to do was this should in my life
I should write more I should should get
up earlier I should make this a priority
I was just shooting all over myself and
and and for me like it took this this
sort of reprioritization to start
focusing on that bit of creativity it
took it took that metaphorical car crash
to realize I wasn't as creative as I
wanted it to be I wasn't contributing
how I wanted to be I didn't even know
what my priorities were and what I have
found those eventually through time yeah
but it probably would have been some
other sort of car crash or at least some
vague accident yeah I wish I mean I
really wish it wouldn't have been my
mother dying and man I I wish I would
have had more time with her yeah so when
we I first started like down this road
my my vision was okay if I can pay off
as much debt as possible or get rid of
like you know all these payments that
I've accumulated like maybe I could
switch jobs and be a barista you know 30
40 hours a week it was that was a way
better situation it sounded like a way
better situation than you know working
80-hour weeks
I just wanted to reclaim my time and
then I thought oh maybe maybe one day if
like if I'm a really good barista and if
maybe Josh can join me I sabri's that
maybe we can like open up a coffee shop
or something like that that is where I
kind of saw my direction going if it
wasn't for Josh let's say you know you
didn't work at the corporation I
probably still would have ended up being
a barista but it it may not have been my
choice thank you thank you thank you
come on down daddy
hello what's your name my name is Tammy
hey Tammy are you from Adelaide - that
makes sense
yeah you liking a delay on favorite city
in Australia yeah yeah Los Angeles
pretty awesome Missoula is pretty
awesome yeah over you know unfortunately
he's kind of falling off to the side of
older getting rid of things see here
tonight I brought my friend instead so
that's okay my family we were quite poor
growing up my mom was a single mum and
we accumulated a lot of things it's been
because of you guys that I have freely
started to look at my things a very
different way and especially things that
have been handed down you know there
have been expected to be kept and things
like that
and it's been able to let me let go of a
lot of that type of thing so thank you
very much for that thank you
so my question kind of comes from the
fact that my mom's actually moved in
with us recently and with her has come
her things her many many things yes she
I would say she has she was a hoarder
and as a growing up you don't really
notice it so much it's just part of who
they are you know and I'm really proud
of her for what she's achieved while
she's been moving in with us but it
still means my house is full of stuff
and more stuff because of her things so
I suppose what I'm asking is how do I
keep everyone motivated to keep moving
through it all because sometimes it
feels like it's just me and I've got two
little children as well go to and a four
year old so I'm trying to instill these
really good values in them I definitely
see a lot of value in that but just
trying to get everyone to keep going and
tape you know cuz it is a long way till
we actually save a lot so there are five
people in the household then including
your two kids yeah how old are the kids
two and four two and four okay so have a
four year old and the thing I noticed
about my daughter is she she's a
biological father as well and when she
goes to his house he's definitely not a
hoarder but he's not a minimalist either
and I say you come to our house and it's
relatively tidy right and there just
isn't excess stuff and the reason I
asked about your kids is I've noticed
with her that her first day or so
sometimes two days returning back to our
house eventually it's like a sigh of
relief right and so also keep in mind
that you're not just doing this for your
own sanity which you are and that's good
you have to start with yourself but it's
also for the stability of your family
and realizing that when she brings stuff
into the house and if it if it feels
chaotic to to you it it certainly feels
chaotic to your kids and the problem is
our children but I've learned they
become vessels for our anxiety we don't
mean for that to happen our number one
job should be to enjoy and then educate
our children and accept the way that we
educate them is usually through our
actions and when we become anxious
overwhelmed they also become anxious or
overwhelmed they don't have the
vocabulary to say that but it changes
their behavior and it manifests in
different ways with with different
individuals and then with kids it can
manifest and outbursts it can manifest
and and bad behavior it can manifest and
and them going off and just being alone
or being too quiet I mean there are a
bunch of ways that it can can sort of
come out so also keep in mind why you're
doing it now I say all that to say you
said how do I get them motivated they
also whether it's your mother or your
husband who is falling off the wagon
it sounds like they also need to know
why so I during during the talk I was
given and I asked the question how might
your life be better with less and you
can answer that question you're gonna
know what the answer is I and if I were
you I would write that down how am i my
life be better with less less than what
you have right now and because I know
from some of you in here it's like well
I could finally take control of my
finances and some of you like well I can
finally start to write that book that I
really want to write and for some of you
it's going to be you know I'll finally
have the opportunity to refocus on my
health for other people if I can
contribute to my community in a
meaningful way and for some of you just
be like yeah that's easier to clean my
house
great whatever the what is the why for
you that's important and knowing what
knowing what that why is important but
it's gonna be different for your mom
it's gonna be different for your husband
and it's gonna be different for your
kids and so also understanding their why
and so asking that question in different
ways how might your life be better with
less well and maybe you could to say you
know what would make you calmer what
what are the things you're struggling
with right now figure out how
simplifying their life not the act of
decluttering cuz that's terrifying
especially to someone like like your mom
who you've categorized as a hoarder I
totally get that it's gonna be
terrifying if you say hey can you get
rid of some of your stuff right but if
you could say what are you struggling
with and then maybe I can help and one
of the ways we can help is by
simplifying could you talk to your
mother or father into playing the 30-day
minimalism game couldn't you for those
of you who don't know the 30-day
minimalism game is it's it's a game that
Josh and I came up with because we know
how boring decluttering can be so we
came up with a game where you could
introduce a little friendly competition
basically you find a spouse or a parent
or a friend or a co-worker or an enemy
whatever and you all agree to start
getting rid of stuff and you start on
the first day of the month and you get
rid of one thing each and then on the
second day the money that you're rid of
two things each and then on the third
day of the month three things each and
so forth and so on
it's really easy at first but then you
know by day 20 it gets a little harder
and the 21 is even a little bit harder
there and then by day 25 you're like oh
my god I gotta get rid of 26 things
tomorrow whoever goes the longest wins
if everybody makes it to the end the
month whoa everybody wins because each
of them would have gotten rid of about
500 items I think that's a great
approach just because you could bet
something like I don't know like
something that you really really love
let's say you want I'm just throwing
this out there just may not there may or
may not be a good idea but let's say
that you really like it when your
husband cooks dinner for the family and
that you know and you can bet him that
all right if I went you cook dinner for
the family and if you win then you know
he can pick something that he really
wants you to do I mean it can make it a
little bit interesting and motivate him
to do this because if it's something
that he really wants you to do then he's
going to that really came out wrong you
see what the Australians mind go
immediate
only in Australia no I love you
Australian but but I think he's doing
wrong with it the other thing too I just
thought I was like man like I'm sure
they get you stuff for Mother's Day I'm
sure they get you stuff for Easter the
gay stuff for Christmas and they're
probably always asking you like what
they want and you can ask them like we
play the 30 day minimalism game with me
or I don't know I'm just I'm just saying
it baby you could use that as a little
bit of leverage to just like I don't
want anything in fact the best Christmas
gift with if we could remove stuff from
the house that would be awesome but but
however you want to approach that but
you know the bottom line is though is
that we are not ever gonna be able to
force anyone to becoming a minimalist in
fact Josh now we go on the road you know
what our conversion rate is and
minimalism it's it's zero because that's
not what we're doing this is it's
impossible to convert someone's to
minimalism by definition what we're
doing is is we're sharing a story and
there there is a recipe here with
ingredients that people can tweeze out
and apply to their own lives so try it
helping them find like Josh said those
ingredients that will help motivate to
help inspire them thank you
all right before we move on if you're
listening to this at home and you have a
comment or tip for anyone who's asking a
question today you can give us a call
for zero six two one nine seven eight
three nine or you can send a voice memo
right from your phone to podcast at the
minimalists comm it's my favorite part
of the show at the very end we air the
comments and tips from our listeners
Ryan what time is it gunshots no minutes
that was lightning oh because it's time
for our lightning round Oh America I
guess anyway yeah lightning round
we usually answer questions of social
media we're at the minimalist on Twitter
and Instagram and Facebook but since
you're here today we'll try to give you
actually what we'll do is we'll ramble
on a bit but we'll come up with a pity
answer eventually that you'll be able to
share on social media if you'd like we
call the minimal Maxim's because that
sounds more impressive than short
answers and our friend Jessica Lynne
Williams back there in the back she live
tweets from the show and also she
catalogues all of our pet the answers
over at minimal Maxim's calm ladies and
gentlemen Jessica Lynne Williams thank
you for everything Jess
howdy what's your name yeah let's go
brother God dude this is [ __ ] love
this guy
[Applause]
and what's your question about
minimalism helping people everyday lives
you know using stuff based on need and
based on you know holding on to things
that add value there's interesting
wow I'm actually I would like to broaden
out a bit and ask you your views on like
corporations who use a lot of resources
and that create a lot of the stuff a lot
of waste lot [ __ ] and you know
capitalism is all about the accumulation
of capital and more and more and more
and how minimalism sort of fits into
that and just the relationship between
minimums and capitalism
normally Josh and I don't really talk
about things like this but since he
asked let's go for it
so so we were actually during the doing
like a little meet-and-greet beforehand
for the people who paid more money for
the good seats thank you all for that so
we were just we're actually talking
about the the use of resources and thus
the responsible use of resources because
I think we've all agreed at this point
that we all need to consume some stuff
we're all wearing clothes in here
we all ate some food today so
consumption is not inherently wrong
however we see 5,000 advertisements a
day and those advertisements are backed
by demographers writers statisticians
and even psychologists and those
advertisements main function are to
aggregate eyeballs onto a product or
service right and so because we're faced
with so many of those messages
eventually we just break down and and
say okay I think I need that I'm
scrolling through my Instagram feed and
I see these shoes or this t-shirt and
even though I have shoes and a t-shirt I
feel like I need that particular thing
in order to to satisfy me right there's
an entire industry called the fast
fashion industry talks about a little
bit in our documentary it used to be
that we had two seasons a year warm and
cold right you put on a coat in the
winter and you took it off in the summer
and you're good to go and now thanks to
companies like H&M we have 52 seasons a
year and that's a problem
and so what I'll tell you is I don't
think corporations are inherently evil
or bad
I don't think capitalism is inherently
evil or bad in fact I will tell you that
capitalism is the best system that we
have right now however and this is the
big but what we are seeing right now is
not true capitalism especially in the
developed world
especially in America what we see is
corporatism and so I think your question
is around corporatism we have a
corporate influence in our politics and
thus we have a corporate influence in
the regulations that we have or I should
say the lack of regulations I'm not a
huge fan of government regulation to be
honest with you however I think there
are times when government regulation
actually increases the liberty of the
individuals and when that's the case
I'll give you some easy examples clean
air and clean water we could all agree
those are good things right it's weird
that that has become a political stance
in America that well I mean the city of
flint which is just up the road from
from where we grew up
the water is poisoned by lead and that's
because we didn't have the appropriate
regulations in place the checks in place
even though we had the regulations on
the books we didn't have the appropriate
checks in place and certain corporate
interests that fund the politicians who
make the decisions got in the way of the
people's health and in a very real way
that's happening now with the way that
we consume things we're consuming more
than ever and with that becomes more the
more waste than ever the more you
consume the more wastes you produce so
Ryan and I aren't up here advocating a
zero waste lifestyle
I think that's extreme and I applaud
people who do that just like I applaud
people who are monks well I think that's
a rather extreme lifestyle someone who
goes and meditates for 18 hours a day
I'm amazed by that I'm amazed by someone
who loses zero waste lifestyle but I
think for most of us the key isn't to
buy nothing to consume nothing to
produce zero waste I think the key is to
radically reduce the amount of
non-essential goods that we need in the
Western world we spend no in America we
spend 1.2 billion dollars
non-essential goods every year I'm sorry
that's that's wrong there must be a
glitch its 1.2 trillion dollars that
doesn't sound like a big difference but
let me explain to you what a trillion is
like I were to give you a million
dollars every single day to spend a
million dollars and you could spend it
every single day you could have spent a
million dollars every day since the
birth of the Buddha 2600 years ago and
you still wouldn't have spent a trillion
dollars by now we're buying over a
trillion dollars in non-essential goods
every single year we spend 250 billion
dollars on charitable giving every year
that means we spent 1.2 trillion on non
essentials 250 billion on charitable
giving we spend the trillion dollars
more every single year on cheap [ __ ] we
don't need
than we do on helping other people so
what's the solution that's what we think
we're the solution yeah I think I think
ultimately it'll be me and Ryan I mean
we are the solution
I mean we're awesome they'll get us
wrong but it's gonna take more than us
yeah we're a very small part of this
Ryan and I can't be the change we can
simply be a voice and everyone who do we
touch who we thought can be an echo of
that voice I think from a government
level it has to do with that's why Pitts
the answer of the voice and you can
clean that up somewhere and in
post-production yes but I think
ultimately I think ultimately some
government regulation to step in that
would increase our Liberty I think part
of that has to do with the amount of
advertisements that we see if we see
5,000 advertisements a day we could have
some regulations to to quash that
but I thought so think that it starts
with us I mean the third-largest city in
the world is the city called cell Paulo
and said in Brazil in 2007 they outlawed
billboards and removed 15000 billboards
removed another 30,000 pile-on and
Markie signs and they took a poll about
a year later to ask folks what they
thought about it and overwhelming the
population was like yes this is what
we've wanted the whole time you have
finally listened to us and the way that
we get politicians to listen is we find
a way to get corporate money out of
politics and if you can figure that one
out please let me know how
yeah I I'll just give you my pet the
answer
capitalism is awesome crony capitalism
is ruining our environment and it's
depleting our resources thanks brother
we're doing good on time come on down
howdy remind me your name brother Greece
thanks for coming it was awesome it's
not [ __ ] around
so after tour I'm getting that haircut
Aaron I [ __ ] love it I've heard you
guys talk about some of the means
misconceptions I wondered sort of not so
much from a misconception point of view
but is there anything you guys
minimalism or essentialism that you just
oh yes don't talk about this either but
since you asked a few things one is I
was walking past a furniture store
recently what city were we're in Atlanta
and it said minimalist pricing and I
here's the problem like Ryan and I
actually sell some products you know we
sell books right
we created a bag last year a travel bag
it's the one that we use in fact we were
with the tour promoter and he's like you
guys have some sort of weird deal with a
we're all carrying the same bag and it's
like well we owned the company or we
owned the small sliver of the company
and so yeah thanks
but with a way that we the way that we
position that bag we could have like
just sold out and said all right let's
let's let's sell as many of these things
as we can but the way that we we put it
out there is hey you probably don't need
this back and and that was the thing
that was most important to me I didn't
want to encourage someone to consume
something they they didn't need or
wouldn't add value to their lives in
some way right and so I think that using
minimalism because that's whatever they
see as being a trend or the hot thing to
sell something is a problem now is
selling something a problem no I think
that's all part of the the sort of the
transaction of consumption I think
that's necessary right the other thing
that I've seen recently is it's in that
same vein is there companies like the
gap you go in there they have t-shirt
it's like it's a black t-shirt and it
says minimalism across the front and
you're like well wait a minute like I
don't even know yeah you don't know why
we're not selling t-shirts right so a
few years ago on April Fool's Day the
other April Fool's here is that just
okay
Ryan and I we put out the minimalist
t-shirt it was like and I wrote the copy
how a shitty fast fashion company would
write the copy to make it sound really
appealing
so in April first it was introducing the
only t-shirt you'll ever want or the
only a t-shirt you'll ever need the only
t-shirt produced by the minimalist and
the way I wrote it was like that it's it
was created by enthusiastic young
workers from Shenzhen China and it was
just a fancy way to say slave labor and
and and that's really what were what
we're doing what we're promoting through
the the advertising or marketing side of
things and in whether it's the gap or
anyone else we're talking about here
that it's in fast fashion I don't think
these companies are inherently bad I
think it becomes a race to the bottom
though
and it's like whatever is new whatever
is trendy whatever we can do to sell
some more units this quarter and if
minimalism is a product that I ain't
buying it that's my pit the answer the
only thing that really comes to mind for
me is when I first started on this road
Colin had 52 things and then it just
kind of became the hundred thing
challenge and like it could became this
like numbers game and I was just really
silly to me um all right I think it was
it was last year on her documentary tour
this guy came up to us and he was like
man you guys are great
but you know this other person they're
killing you in the minimalism game and
they only got like 22 things and man
they really get it and I'm like okay
like it that's that's it that's what his
version of minimalism is is he wants to
travel around like Colin did then that
makes sense for him but when it for me I
get really competitive so if I started
to count my stuff then it would have
become a game for me and then I would
have lost the whole point of why I was
doing what I was doing so that is that
is really really frustrating
I guess my pithy answer would be man if
minimalism is about counting your stuff
I'm the first loser
it's funny you talking about that so
like yeah if it really came down to
owning like essentially nothing I was
thinking about it was the strangest
thing I've seen in a long time we were
in st. Petersburg Florida we owned a
coffee shop down there and I was driving
down First Avenue south and I'm just
driving driving driving I look over and
there's this really fit like 60-year old
man he's crossing the street at the
crosswalk and he is just buck naked
I mean completely naked not a stitch of
clothes on his entire body and and and
so like there's this fine line between
like figuring out what is appropriate
for you and then just truly getting rid
of it all right and I realized that
that's one side of the continuum and
hoarding is on the other side of the
continuum and I'm probably somewhere in
between thanks for being here thanks so
much man I appreciate it
mark so for those of you who don't know
who mark is at the end of 2014 or
actually throughout 2014 Ryan and I
spent a year on the road but we ended
our hundred city tour here in Australia
in 2014 now we would come to an event
and we'd meet people and they'd say hey
it's great you're here for a few hours
or for half a day or whatever and now
you're leaving how do I meet open-minded
people locally and we didn't really have
a good answer to that and so we started
something called minimalist org and it's
100 free local meetup groups all over
the world and one of those cities is
Adelaide and our community leader here
is Mark thank you more awesome so if you
want to connect with open-minded people
locally just go to minimalist org click
on a delight or if you listen to this at
home click on your city and you could
find the group's they interact online
you can get support with you know
decluttering or the careers or
relationships or health or whatever
you're looking for support on and they
also tend to meet once a month in person
as well so you can help support other
people just as you're getting support
you're also gonna find a bunch of
genuine awesome people like Marc at
these at these meetings amen
no reason question but just a bit of
promotion for you guys but I just wanted
to share my story very quickly a couple
years ago us
surfing Netflix on a quite afternoon and
when yeah let's watch something that had
some value and gets me thinking and I
mean what the hell is a minimalist
I mean I'm gonna watch this straight
away got me guns blazing a couple of
days later to my wife we've got to do
this we're gonna do this we're to do
this but do you know what getting the
Internet energy out there first and just
letting it chill out afterwards and
seeing what it becomes that was the
foundation building so two years later a
lot of things have changed in in a great
way that life is now a journey there's
no destinations anymore there's no goals
there's no nothing it's enjoy every
single day but journey to work every
single day is a whole lot nicer now than
it ever used to be so what I want to say
is already tonight met some absolutely
fantastic people so get on board get on
to mr. old force face Adelaide we are
really gonna ramp it up this year with
the support of everyone being involved I
met some brilliant people tonight with
some great stories as well who suddenly
discover no you know you're not weird
you're not strange you're just doing it
as you should be doing it living a life
with less and much more meaningfully so
thanks guys
no thank you mark I mean states like it
do you like Josh and I like you're gonna
love guys like Mark cuz he's just like
us thanks mark I think we'll have time
for two more we'll get to those in a
moment but first let's move on to our
added value portion of the show so we're
where Ryan and I talk about something
that has added value to our lives
recently and since we're here in
Adelaide which like I said I think is
our favorite Australia City especially
after some of the experiences we've had
this is the most you know what love
about Adelaide I don't feel like rushed
when I'm here it's like I've so laid
back here and we've had like I want to
say three meal three meals Mariah and I
have at least had three meals here in
couple cups of coffee I have had nothing
but outstanding food an outstanding
coffee here did you got you guys are
doing it right and it's all independent
places like I just love this place so
much yeah that's really awesome so Ryan
what is added value to you what's the
biggest thing that stood out to you I've
got I got two recommendations after
kolja if you haven't been there go it is
some of the best food I've had in
Australia I am NOT just saying that the
rest I get some of the best food so
we've been on the road for the last 12
months with 50 cities and I think it's
some of the best food I've had just
period it's definitely top three hands
down well I mean what they do is first
off there's an amazing environment there
it's just kind of a home home feel
environment but then like their food it
seems like really like chaotic at first
because there's like sardines on the
menu and like pork neck and some other
really random stuff but it's every
single dish is done so intentionally
with the flavors like you get you get
this amazing like strong flavor but it
is the best flavor you've ever had you
okay
you gotta check it out it's like a mad
scientist married a chef and they just
started making a bunch of [ __ ] they are
they're just killing it over there and
then I stopped earlier today at a coffee
shop please say please I don't know who
I think the gala was talking to she
knows the shop she's killing it over
there it's actually it's the phone now
we tried to find good coffee in Perth we
failed but we didn't really win it and
we didn't have a whole lot of time so
that's not personal we it was our it was
our time time constraints fault
Sydney found some really awesome coffee
fountain found not so awesome coffee in
Brisbane but what I'll tell you the
first time I was able to find a
pour-over was was at police say please
and and I know filter coffee isn't like
so popular here just go to police say
please order a filter coffee a pour-over
you're welcome
we had breakfast today like the whole
team went there to this place called I
think it's called saison is that right
yeah and it's like Mexican brunch in
Adelaide Australia unbelievable
holy crap I don't even know what to say
other than thank you for existing and
your coffee was stellar dead like a
filter batch coffee that was awesome
yeah wasn't the holy good the whole
experience was great in this everyone
Adelaide I meet is so nice so I'd say
the staff is nice but y'all are nice so
you know that and let's move on real
quick - right here right now it's the
this is the segment of the podcast where
we talk about what's going on in the
lives of the minimalists so Ryan and I
are just finishing up this crazy
50 city tour here in Australia we have
three events after this tonight actually
we got one of them in Auckland so we're
going over to New Zealand and then we're
finishing up in Melbourne two events
there and then we're done touring for a
long time we're finishing up our second
documentary we gave a talk earlier
tonight and we actually filmed that talk
and a beautiful warehouse space in Los
Angeles we filmed it in a few theaters
throughout the year but it looked like a
stand-up comedy special without comedy
and so we decided to rent this beautiful
warehouse space that was in line with
our aesthetic and we're building the
next documentary around that talk and
next month were going to Dayton Ohio to
film some of our back stories talk about
what's going on there there's a real
crisis of meaning going on there it's
the overdose capital but they don't
really have a drug problem they have a
meaning problem and I think a lot of us
have run into that at least at one point
in our lives I know I certainly did
where I'm like wow this whatever I'm
doing right now is a meaningful and I
can keep going down this path I'm not
gonna find meaning on this path so
instead of continuing to run in that
direction maybe I should just turn
around and walk the other way and and
try to find something else that it was
that is that will bring purpose a sense
of meaning and joy to my life
that's what this next documentary is
about is diving deep on on that topic of
meaning and so look for that later this
year in the meantime we're continuing to
do with the podcast so we just built
this new podcast studio in Los Angeles
and we're adding a video component to
the podcast hopefully this summer and
because we keep them on the podcast 100%
advertisement free because
advertisements you're damn right they
suck and we rely on the support of folks
like you and if you listen to those
folks at home who are listening to this
we want to say thank you to our patreon
supporters because of you that were able
to do that and eventually we're gonna
add this video component which is crazy
expensive to hire someone and then if
you do all the video editing and filming
and all the equipment as well and so
what we do each week is we record a
bonus episode of the podcast it's called
a PostScript episode and we call it the
minimalists private podcast it shows up
right in your normal podcast feed so if
you listen to the minimalist podcast on
Apple podcasts or overcast or wherever
you get your podcast there's a second
podcast called the minimalists private
podcast where we just put that out for
our patreon supporters so if you want to
support us keep the podcast on 2%
advertisement free none of the money
goes to me or Ryan it's just for the
podcast you can go to the minimalists
com click donate it at the top and
you'll become a patreon supporter and
right there you'll be able to get you'll
get access right from your phone to
these bonus episodes so let's go ahead
and answer a couple questions for a
bonus episode if y'all are cool with
that let's do it before we wrap up I
just want to say one other thing about
we were just talking about on the little
bonus podcast we were doing there we
were talking about anchors Ryan and the
83 anchors that I that I had in my life
and I can't believe you listed every
single one of them in alphabetical order
memorized no I think some of those
things actually served an important
purpose in my life at one point not all
of them some of them were just I just
picked up an anchor for no reason to
started carrying it around with me and
it was heavy and I just kept carrying it
that was the first thing on your list it
was
actual anchor yeah that's why it was
alphabetized but it feels like the like
sometimes we just pick up things and it
does no good for us because someone else
told us to pick it up right we've let
someone else dictate our life whether
that's through the inbox or just someone
else's to-do list has now become our
to-do list someone else's obligation
then becomes our obligation and so if
some of my anchors were other people's
anchors and I picked up those anchors
and I forgot to put them down
however there were other things in my
life that just somehow magically
transformed into anchors over time there
were things that once added value to my
life that no longer add value now and so
I think the most important thing when
we're letting go is realizing the things
that add value to my life today may not
add value tomorrow and so the one thing
I need to hold on to is my willingness
to let go because as my life changes as
my circumstances change and so do the
things that truly add value to my life
and so I'm willing to set things down
I'm also willing to bring new things
into my life knowing that damn well they
might become an anchor one day so I
better be willing to let that go I love
that metaphor man because let's say you
know you pick up an actual anchor and
you're like walking up a hill with it
and they see another rank and you're
like oh I don't want that anchor to you
pick it up and then eventually really I
was like oh [ __ ] like I can't walk up
the hill with both these anchors like
you made the decision to pick that
anchor up you can always make the
decision to put it back down always and
if you leave here tonight with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for being there also
thank you so much thank you thank you
take you take you take you take you
seriously thank you so much out of late
[Applause]
hi Josh and Ryan this is Candice from
Niagara Falls Ontario I was just
listening to your podcast on religion
with mr. bell and mr. Morgan
I just wanted to recommend the book that
I found very intriguing and
knowledgeable it's called the Buddhist
boot camp by timber Hawkeye I found a
lot in it just based on the fact that
you could be whatever religion you want
and Buddhism will just make you e better
whatever you are hey guys it's Kylie
calling from the Gold Coast of Australia
it was really awesome seeing you on your
tour stop here I just had a quick
comment in regards to the recent podcast
that you did about religion one of the
callers asked for resources to do a
spirituality that would suit a
minimalist and I wanted to recommend the
DAO to change the daodejing is an
ancient spiritual text but it's really
more of a philosophy veteran religion
there are some people especially in
China though who do follow it a bit more
like a religion but it's basically an
easy read it's just a set of 81 verses
more like poems and they're about all
different things but they're all to do
with living a life of meaning and
passion and happiness and there are many
many verses about living simply and not
being materialistic I don't come across
many people who are actually familiar
with this book the data change but it's
actually the number two most printed
book in all of history second only to
the Bible and many scholars do consider
it the wisest book ever written so I
definitely think anyone that's
interested in a spiritual path that has
something strongly to do with minimalism
it's definitely worth that worth picking
up a copy of the daodejing hey guys this
is chaplain Fred from Sarasota Florida
hey i listening to the friends edition
of the podcast and i just want to say it
really really touched me that Josh was
talking about his friend who voted for
Trump and and he didn't end the way that
you guys were able to go forward and do
projects together and and you know
honestly that's the way it's supposed to
you know the political pendulum in our
two-party system swings back and forth
you know if it swings really high to the
left it tends to swing really high to
the right but at the end of the day
we're all still Americans you know we're
all supposed to be countrymen and I was
just really really encouraged to hear
the way you guys articulate you know
your views on that I really think that's
the basis of a new conversation that has
to happen and minimus --tz--